so you say that writers don't spend
enough time making sure that the idea
that they're sort of putting out there
is viable wouldn't you you think that
most writers are choosing an idea that's
very personal to them in some sense even
if it's the story's not really about
them it's a core idea that affects them
why wouldn't it translate if it's so
personal and deep and rich to that
writer wouldn't putting something so
sort of deep and personal that the
writer is choosing to focus on be enough
to make the script viable well that's a
great question first let me say when I
talk about writers I'm talking about
myself too because I'm a writer and
that's still the main thing I do and I
make these things that I might call
mistakes so it's not me on HIGH saying
oh those writers what idiots they heart
it's me saying we all naturally do this
stuff I just want to make that clear to
your audience sure but that's a great
question and and I've made I don't I
wouldn't call it a mistake but I've done
this myself many times which is write
something that is personal to me that I
think I felt something deeply about so
audiences will too and one often we know
one hopes they can pull that off and
there are some pitfalls in that approach
that often happen one of them being that
we so internalize what we went through
what we were thinking and feeling and
why it mattered so much to us in our
life to put it actually on the page in a
way that audience is looking at a
character based on us having experiences
based on ours for the audience to get
those things that are internal to us is
harder than it looks
and often just because we felt it deeply
doesn't mean that we can write a
character feeling that same thing deeply
and the audience will get it sometimes
they will sometimes those are the best
movies but a lot of times they won't and
a lot of times that thing that we went
through in our personal life that
mattered so much to us doesn't
necessarily have the ingredients of an
entertaining to watch story for an
audience like a movie or television
audience a story that builds and
complicates and gets worse and are
really fun to watch way often when we're
writing real life and this is any kind
of true story and I've worked a lot on
true stories and people come to me a lot
with true story because I worked on
two brothers for instance it's it's kind
of where I got my start professionally
what I've really learned is that true
stories are sometimes harder than
fiction because you real life doesn't
have story structure typically real life
doesn't have the things that we writers
have learned that audiences need to be
really emotionally invested and
entertained and to stay emotionally
invested entertained over the course of
an hour half hour or two hours it just
doesn and writers have to bring a lot of
manipulation to a true story to make it
comprehensible to an audience and to
make it be that kind of emotional
journey with that kind of classic
narrative build to it and entertainment
value to it it just doesn't come
naturally we have to kind of impose it
so a lot of times the things we've gone
in our own life we don't have
perspective on them we can't see them
from that third party person that has a
very different life from us and how do
we portrayed on the page or on screen in
a way that they will be really
entertained and invested in this
character like us and often we aren't
able to write that character with enough
perspective and enough clarity so that
people will get what they're going
through because to us it's already so
obvious it's like a given it's inside of
our head but getting it outside of our
head and onto the page in a way that
others will really get it I think it's
harder than it looks
and so when you're identifying an idea
for a story coming from a place that is
something passionate to you or that you
have experienced I think is a good start
but it's usually not enough you usually
have to sort of test it by putting
yourself in the shoes of a sort of third
party anonymous viewer with a different
life story than yours
how do you make this something that's
that's universal because our own pain
and our own drama and our own situations
don't necessarily have deep and
compelling universally relatable
elements to them that any one or
millions of people would be able to
instantly grasp and be emotionally
invested I use that term a lot of
emotional investment because to me
that's the key thing we're always going
for there's an audience that's the key
thing we want we want to care and a lot
of this focus on the idea is about
finding an idea that people you know
people strangers millions of strangers
will have a chance of really caring
about this idea caring about this
character these characters in this
situation what makes them care and so
these seven elements a lot of it is
about me trying to put into words here
are the qualities that I think are
inherent in stories that can make an
audience care and when it's coming from
our own life experience a lot of times
some of those elements could be missing
and we may not realize it
you